FRNUARY
>> THANKS SO M
OR TIDENT MET WITH AIR AN FE EA
TO REMAIN ANIVE AN
TO ME AST T MOR FACMORE,
ARE IN TID
VA IRAN.
H
CRITMO
IN
BIE FOR TH  W GREETCROWN CES ACB
UR JOURNALI.NGLY IS IN JEDDAFOR
WHITEOU
BELIEV,
PARTICULARLY ON THISDAWHIL MIDDT
>>S A
Y  RAPIDE,
ME PRESI P LEADERS IN THE REGIO.
T
LAY OUTH OF THE
. SEES
THIS PT T OF THE W I A ALLY CHA
THRLD.
THE PREN
PROBABLYONE OF THE STEM,
THA NT REG
THAN WHEN HE WAS VNCE
THAT SOUND YOU PYE
ROM HIREMARKS S
MAKING CLEAR TE LEADERS TH
RERE EARLI
TO WAS INDD AND TURN A BLIND E
CAL CONCERN TS IN THE REGION
ADNI PLAEDTHE PRESIDENT SAYING
VETH.EDTI
THTINGES, BETWEETHE CROWN PRINCN
HAT WAMEETING,
HEAT AND THE WHITE HOUSE
ORREL THE DIVIDUAL THAU.
HODA
YOUK TO
WHITE HOUSE OFFICIALS W THEY
THEY KNEW THE GOING TO GET
BUT IT WAS IOR AT
R STRATEGIC
IV IT ISE HE PREWH ABOUT THE MOO
I WAS STRAIGCK T F
S STD TODAY.
WHAT -G
DNET WITH
THN IN
T GO DEAL WITE  AND THE N OF TH
UNITED
AND NOLEAVE A UM HERE,
HAS GOTTOSIVE OF THE
EWS FROM OFFICIALSTH
REGIIN THE OF HIS RK
CIHOME. IS NOT GOING AWAYIME
SO WHITESET TH
, NOT NECESSARILY ON PED. CHTA .
I'GON GLOBAL
ANT STAFWRITERT THE NE TE YOU. O
E OTR WATHPRESID
THAT GREETING, THAT MEETIN
>> LK, YOUW,E
KEWILL S LIKE
TO LOOK LIKEHYPOCRE T COME
P BETW VD
N E E.HE SAID HEOU
AR P
URDERI "ON POST"UM
INMEETIN
MBER, A LOT OF IT THHOT ANY FAVE
RUN TO INVADE
ATE
ENERGY
ABIAOT
IN THE SHORF
ADMINIRA OWHD OMPLISH  RR
THCLB
Y.WN.T
AND THEN IS AL, WH
CRPR HADIS O OE N IN EE HIIN
NT
T TERPRETED ASMELD THE PRESIDENT
R JOE BIDEN  GANTED,
E SH BUMPELDRNNON-PATATUS.W DEC.
CONVERSATION THAT YOU HAVIIG.E
TH
T GOING TO WALK AWAY FRO
HAVE THEAUDIS  TOMAT
UPESCH IBLABLE O
HAVE THEMMITTE IN YEMEN.
AND YPAQN D TOH EVERYTHING LONGF
T MEAN THE GREATER PRODUCTIO
COTEAS A WLE TO BE MEETIN
GCC ABROAD?
ELE AB T V WASIV
REITION OF ASIDENTIAVINTHO SAIDE
PONG PRIVA TODWITH LDEHE HANAGLH
T A PRETTYT  SAY THAT OHLY OUA I
ISONTOREONCEINR ITS BILITY, FOR
JAMAAS A VERY FAMILIAR
CONVERSATI
SAUDI ARIAOAR . IE KEAC PROBAMA
PRESIDENT OF T USTATES
AND THE CROWN PRINCE.
IT IS .A PAINE THOUGHOR
OE BID
S SOMEONE